all right daryl daryl
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally louisiana
and tell me about your family you had
both with your parents growing up both
of my parents
nine kids nine kids how was your
childhood
a child who was very very rough
and because i go back it's remembering a
lot of things when i was five years old
i remember the abusive
physical things that my dad done to me
through his alcoholism and i have a twin
sister
and so i'm the youngest about i'm the
youngest boy out
of the four and five girls but i grew up
real hard i don't know what it was but
my dad really chastised me through a lot
of things that
he hindered one of my biggest dreams and
one of my biggest dreams i wanted to be
a nfl football player but
but through the beatings
i have a stab wound my father actually
cut me
he stabbed me i almost lost my life and
i was six years old at that time but
through that childhood and they said
coming up
i was abused constantly
i can come home from school and my dad
would find
some crazy reason to just
be on me and my mom would do everything
in her power to stop him and i was
the only child out of the nine kids that
my father
abuse
today when i when i look back at it
my father saw some things in me
that he wanted to do
i i just i'm gonna keep it at the point
where
where he just abused me and um
deprived me of anything that i wanted to
do
and i just tried everything i could to
excel but
i left home at the age of 15.
i was playing music and i started
traveling and
i got tired of a lot of different
nationalities and
drugs became a part of my life i started
using drugs at the age of 15.
i've been in the penitentiary five times
assaults choking guns using drugs
prostitution
i was actually selling myself
you know in new jersey in new york
i've been there near to the brink of
death
people have beaten me um
my life
my life was just harsh and my father
my mom for my mom probably lived they
stayed married 62 years but
i was in prison when my father died he's
been gone six years now
and he never really
he never actually told me that he loved
me
i was the son my father didn't do
anything for
and i finished high school
barely but i've excelled
in my life a lot more than my other
brothers
but i was never given compassion i was
never
awarded with any type of affection any
of those things
at the age of 19 i could go back and
remember
when i did my first gospel album as a
professional drummer
i recall my dad punching me in my face
he didn't want me to do these things he
told me i was
not permitted to even come around the
house
because i was a child that did what i
wanted to do
and not what he wanted me to do and
it confused me to it really transfused
me to the point where
i thought about suicide i actually
thought about killing my father
i really did you know i wanted to blew
this man's brains out man
and we could never hold a conversation
and i would always try to i wanted to
reach out to my dad and talk to them
because i had friends that
grew up with their fathers and their
fathers did things with them
back when i played baseball my father
wouldn't come to my gangs
and when i did come from the games i
would even get cussed out
punched in them out called all kind of
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
that you'd never be any [ __ ] thing
you know
and man this [ __ ] really redirected my
path
and i strayed away from my home and
i abandoned my family i wanted to love
my mom and she loved me
but i just strayed away from home and
took a path to that man that
just totally [ __ ] me up and i've never
forgiven my first time going to
penitentiary
for home robbery i did
seven years come home stayed home six
months
went back at the penitentiary
distribution
of drugs in five years
came back out did another stint three
years
i shot a man and just this last day
i've been on five years now just last
night
they got me for for fraud
writing bad checks and when i look back
over everything that happened to me
it still hurts me as i talk to you right
now
i have pain in my heart because my
father has known him
i still never heard those words to say
that he loved me
and i want so bad right now to tell my
father that i love him
through all the neglect
that he threw upon me and the weight
that my [ __ ] man the weight that my
father put on me
it still bothers me because
i still don't have an answer to why
here i am now from new orleans
and travel to california
not knowing why i'm i still have a gypsy
spirit
to move around and to try to find out
what it is what is it
what's my achievement in his life
and every time i try to figure this
thing out
i process it the haunting of what my
father does to me
and to hear those words that should
never
be anything you're a [ __ ]
you're a no good child and to think
about the beatings
stitching cards belts chains
boards you name it
i'm still confused i'm 54 years old now
and i still haven't figured out my
directive
and as i said i came here to california
and i'm i was on skid row
but some kind of way and i said i don't
even know that answer
i figured out a way to come out of this
[ __ ]
but as i say the haunting of my father's
torture to me and his words
they still echo in my brain
and i'm still under a lot of hindrance
i'm still a user today
i drink excessively
i have a job
but my days or my nights
are not completed
without the use of me using drugs and i
do this here to escape
my father's voice he haunts me day and
night
i still feel the pain i still feel the
whippings the lashings that you placed
upon me
and sometimes me and my twin sister
which we talked every day i called my
mom every day
and my mom told me all the time she said
y'all i still
can hear it in your voice the pain that
you're going through son
she said your father was a confused man
an uneducated man
that didn't have a clue to what it was
he was supposed to do
but he tortured tortured me
and i don't know if you know anything
about torture
i can go back as far as i remember my
dad
actually put me in the basement
for a weekend and left me there
no food no water
and wouldn't allow my mom to even bring
anything to me
or you know my siblings and you used to
cry out and say daddy why
why daddy why why why doubt
why don't what you did
and he would push them away
smack them
through his alcoholism
he killed me he killed himself
and i still feel this pain
every day and i see me
of my father i see my father in me now
i'm not as deep as he was in alcoholism
but i see the things that he did to me
i inject this on anybody
that comes in my presence i i don't have
i can't have healthy relationships or
anything
because i'm abusive like my father was
to me
it's scary
i really wish i could just find the
answers man to come out
i'm holding back the tears right now
because i'm really hurting
from this [ __ ] man
knowing that i was on the streets
dealing with women and homosexuals
[ __ ] just this morning before i went to
work a homosexual blows at me
you know actually you described my penis
and i got your caller
and in my ignorance
of not knowing what the hell is going on
with myself
i ain't gonna switch this man
i want this [ __ ] to stop
and i need answers
and i just freedom i highly pop all the
time please help me
and i believe he he tries to talk to me
but my spirit is so dull from five years
old
up to 54 now i just can't understand it
and i need help bad
bad i can't even i don't even like to
talk to my own kids
i don't my son was born
i was in penitentiary i never knew my
son
up until five years ago when both of us
walked the same hallways
in the penitentiary that was my that was
one of my nightmares
losing my mom and dad while i was locked
up or even meeting my child
it was alright that this guy seen me one
day and he said
man you look just like kiara i knew that
name but i know we were talking about
and i asked this guy where he was from
and he told me i texted my son from
he said man your son is in the cell
block
i managed to get a letter to him and ask
him to meet me in the chapel
and that's why i met my childhood my
child
was 21 years old a grown man
i never got to hold him never heard him
say his first words
anything
and just as i say the scars from what my
father did to me
my son couldn't even call me dad
and i wanted his respect as his father
but i couldn't command that because i
wasn't a father
i just wanted to reach out and beat him
like my father gave me
because i met you in prison and i felt
like my dad felt about me
so you ain't gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ]
you'll never achieve anything in life
i talked to him the same way my father
did
and that wasn't healthy
now i believe that them scars are still
with my son because my son is back in
penitentiary again
i just gotta try to figure out a way to
get
my get my spiritual my spirit right
and hopefully i can do it before i pass
away
and give my son a different direct
than what i had as a child
right for [ __ ] did you die
but i'm hoping someday
that i can figure this out being in
california and living in the heart
that i've lived in in skid row
man
it is so confusing it is so
hurting when i walk the streets
and see where the [ __ ] my life has
brought me from
my child abuse
and i bring everything everything that
is happening to me today i still blame
it from what my father did
because he never educated me
all he ever did was down there
and said i would be a rock son of a
[ __ ]
and that's where my life is today
that's where my life is
it hurts bro it hurts
it is you know there's you know i know
you're busy man i appreciate you just
hearing my story
just a little bit did i share with you
right now
it makes me feel a little bit better
because
i'm having an opportunity to release
because instead well i have i have no
other
he's bobber up in there
i'm an angry man i'm a violent man
on my job
i'm known for a good employee
and at the same time i'm known for
anything that good gets out of order
with a customer i'm the one called upon
because of my
they don't know about it but because of
the anger
that i distribute i'm called upon to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
i've been asked i've been matched today
today
when i go back to work
and get off at six o'clock i've been
asked
to literally break a guy's bones
for what he's done and
i've already volunteered to do these
things
because i don't give a [ __ ]
and i think i was told i wouldn't be
[ __ ]
so i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ]
rather i die by the gun than knife
whatever and this is why
i'm a loner i keep people
[Music]
distant from me
i'm a widow i had a wife
and my dad abused my wife my mom
and my third year marriage
i literally beat my wife so bad
on the streets i didn't even know
undercover police were right there
and when one of them touched me i
stalked them
i placed so much fear in my wife god
bless and she's deceased now
from lupus this lady
used to be scared to even say good
morning to me
because i treated her like my dad
treated my mom
i would tell the [ __ ] down my face
bring me breakfast
i would eat the food and literally throw
the plate at her
i had and still have
a destructive
mindset and spirit
once i walk out this door and i
set the pattern of my destination
it's not healthy for anybody even say
anything to me
because i don't give a [ __ ] about myself
and i don't give a [ __ ] about the next
person
and that's a destructive lifestyle
maybe i'll die from it maybe i'll get
the opportunity to find out something
that can derail me from this destructive
path that i'm walking on
but in my closing
i want some help
because i'm tired of abusing me
and the people that come into my life
and that's why
i don't have anyone i don't
just as soon as i meet you trust me
you'll be glad to get out of my presence
because i don't give a [ __ ]
peace thank you very much
thank you bro it's good to talk about
thank you you helped me today
you did you helped me today
therapy is a great thing man just man
you do this regularly imagine if you did
this like
three times a week it'd be difficult
you'd be different
i'm so tired